we are more enlightened than our
ancestors because we can look back at
their errors and mistakes yeah right
that's the value of knowing history
because you can look back at it and you
can oh let's not do that again that was
a bad idea right that's why so right now
as we speak in various states cities and
countries they're rolling out this
concept of vaccine passports show your
papers to enter a grocery store a
restaurant a gym a cinema whatever
we've done segregation before it's a bad
idea such a bad idea you had it in the
usa you had jim crow laws you had it in
uh south africa even within our lifetime
apartheid right when you create a
two-tier society and you give certain
rights and privileges and access to own
to one group and another one who is
unclean you don't give it's always a bad
idea i mean literally comedians are now
making jokes about it it's not funny you
know it's it's this is the pr this is
the problem and this is what i mean when
i say human beings haven't involved
right because we still have those
base
primal tribalism yeah i see what you
mean yeah once you start that's why it's
dangerous to see people as enemies
because once you do what do you do with
an enemy what do you do with the threat
you exterminate it
right that is literally how human beings
are
wired and it's so foolish and naive for
people to think that all the bad stuff
that has happened in history
cannot happen again totally and by
recognizing that it can happen again
that's how you stop it yeah from
happening again right all of us
especially when we were younger would
always look i mean you just again just
look at the 20th century like how did
they how did they let that happen like
that doesn't make sense like i know were
they all like how you know how to and
now it's i mean
i i certainly don't ask those questions
anymore because i can see how it happens
that was zooby an independent rap artist
podcast host of real talk with zubi
author public speaker and creative
entrepreneur he was born in england
raised in saudi arabia and is a graduate
of oxford university he's become a
rising figure over the last years whose
authenticity captures the hearts of so
many with his grounding unique
perspective and positive energy zubi has
a compelling level of honesty and does
not shy away from expressing himself so
much has happened in the last 18 months
there has been so much hardship and so
much fear either with people living in
fear of the virus or a fear of speaking
their mind and standing out or fear of
losing their job for a multitude of
reasons and so many people have suffered
whether they've lost a loved one due to
the virus or suffered from the aftermath
of the lockdowns due to depression and
suicide rise in child abuse and neglect
or lack of proper education for children
or stress resulting from the loss of a
business whom they worked their entire
career to build
and even from things that most people
are not even talking about like the
results of mass for the deaf or hard of
hearing not being able to read lips and
i think in order for us to find common
ground and meet each other where we're
at it's helpful to figure out where we
at least agree and move forward from
there
and while we don't get into the data and
the stats in this episode surveys and
polls are now showing that there's often
a big misunderstanding amongst the
majority of people of important factors
about the virus like the hospitalization
rate the death rate and more one-third
of americans think that the
hospitalization rate is over 50 percent
when the actual hospitalization rate is
one to five percent this information is
staggering and matters because if one
person thinks the hospitalization rate
is 50
while another thinks the hospitalization
rate is 0.01 percent then it makes
complete sense where there's so little
common ground on how to move forward and
the reason for this is that the media
and the government have done such a good
job at dividing people and creating fear
what's happening right now is so
polarizing everyone thinks what they do
for a reason and we need to come
together to hear each other out instead
of name-calling and assuming ill intent
every single death is sad every single
heartache that someone has experienced
and gone through throughout this whole
thing whether that's directly from the
virus or the repercussions from the
decisions on how to handle the virus is
sad and i think now more than ever we
need to acknowledge all the ways in
which people have suffered from this so
let's have conversations and when you
begin conversations with loved ones or
people you meet first find where there's
common ground and what you can both
agree on as a starting point zooby
shares authentically where he feels our
priority should be whether you agree
with his thought process or not i hope
by the end of it you feel empowered to
have heard his perspective i can't wait
for you to hear this conversation let's
get into it alright zoomi thank you for
coming on the show today i'm so happy to
have you here happy to be here ellen how
are you so good so i think a lot of my
audience might not know who you are even
though you're like you know very big in
certain realms of the spectrum online
but i think a lot of my audience might
not know who you are so can you tell us
a little bit about your background how
you grew up your music just a little bit
about that yeah sure thing so my name is
zubi i'm an independent rapper author
host of uh the real talk with zubi
podcast i also do coaching and public
speaking as well i've got a very diverse
background i was born in the uk i grew
up in saudi arabia i lived there for
about two decades my family background
is originally from
nigeria and when i was in saudi arabia i
went to an international school so i was
essentially in the american school
system from kindergarten up until fifth
grade so if anyone here is listening and
wondering why i don't obviously sound
british that is why
totally that's like so fascinating that
you had so much diversity within where
you grew up so much like to take from i
think that probably comes from a lot of
how you deal with today and take
perspectives from all over all over
today because of where you grew up in so
many different areas yeah most
definitely i don't have the
perspective from just one single country
or culture i've grown up through a range
of different ones and they've all
influenced me in different ways so i
think the reason why what i do is
effective and why people are really
interested in
me just sharing my views on the worlds
and things i'm seeing
is based on the fact it's just coming
from
a different and a unique perspective not
not anyone else has the same
upbringing i do in the way that i have
it uh let alone combined with
the sort of i guess talent stack i've
got from doing music but also kind of
doing social and political commentary
and fitness stuff all of that in the
combination i do it is really unique so
i just do what i enjoy i try to share a
positive message inspire people motivate
people and encourage people to think
yeah and that's actually one of the main
reasons why i wanted you on the podcast
when i'm like figuring out who i want on
my podcast when i was figuring out for a
whole year you were definitely in my top
ten because if i wanted to delve into
some polarizing and hot button topics i
want to have someone on the show who's
going to be just like super logic based
and also brings people together but says
some really um important things that
kind of blow up the internet sometimes
oh yeah and that's kind of how you are
and what's so cool is that you do talk
about politics sometimes but really your
your focus is on like why people behave
the way that they do you talk about like
uh just culture morality and just
like really important stuff that kind of
brings it together as opposed to just
focusing on like
left right black white like it's just so
fascinating and really i think it really
does help like stir the conversation up
makes it much more interesting yeah most
definitely well i think we live in an
age of false dichotomies where
everything is
there are so many false binaries right
everything is either this or that black
white left right good bad and
there's
there was it uh was it males who said
the
the definition of tyranny is the
deliberate removal of nuance
and i think that's very much what we've
been living through for several years
and perhaps now more than ever certainly
within my own lifetime where
everything's just everyone's looking at
things in this
very clear-cut way
um which
doesn't really reflect reality human
beings are truly
nuanced and unique and
there are more than i mean if you take
something like politics it's often
framed especially here in the usa i mean
you've got 330 million people
in this country
and it's framed as if there's only two
political opinions right everything is
left or right democrat or republican
liberal or conservative and it's treated
as if that's that's all there is and
this happens on a lot of different
issues and i think that's part of why
there's this increasing polarization and
even demonization of the other side the
fact that it's even looked at as if it's
just these two sides and you're either
with us you're against us and
i try not to i try my best not to play
into that too much right i do have my
own opinions and i'm not afraid to put
them out there uh people agree with me
people disagree i talk about everything
under the sun
but at the same time i do my best to not
view
my fellow human beings as
enemies let me say yes and i think in
the media and in politics there's a lot
of value
and a lot of power in encouraging people
to view their fellow citizens or
neighbors sometimes down to friends and
family as enemies as threats and i think
that the more people play into that and
allow themselves to be used as pawns
then
the worst things are going to get and i
think that's what's been happening
certainly a lot over the past 18 months
with the whole politicization of say the
pandemic situation but it was happening
prior to that it happened in my home
country with the whole brexit situation
it happened with the election of donald
trump here in 2016
and again it's all false dichotomies and
artificial binaries yeah and to be
honest that i i totally agree and that's
actually the main reason why like i've
been a little bit nervous to even do
this episode because you know i'm
passionate about a lot of things i talk
about i talk about so many things i talk
about you know veganism plant-based
nutrition um home-birthing homeschooling
respectful parenting like it's a wide
range but the moment that you step into
another topic that your audience isn't
really used to you talking about
um a lot of people can get really upset
because you know inevitably people are
going to disagree with you and
unfortunately a lot of people really
feel like they have to agree with
whoever that they follow or
listen to that they have to agree with
everything that they say and i think
they completely forget that like you can
agree with someone on one thing but that
doesn't mean you're going to agree with
them on everything and that also doesn't
mean that you should shun them
completely from
like just because you disagree with them
on one thing because i mean that's how
we find middle ground that's how we
understand each other if we just listen
to each other and i think just accepting
that reality that it's very rare if
possible whatever to find someone that
agrees with you on everything so it's
important i think to just like hear each
other out and that's what that's why
i've been so nervous because i want i
want to come out and talk more about all
the things because i'm just you know a
passionate person about a lot of things
as you are
um but i also want to like bring people
together and like make sure whoever's
listening like feels heard no matter
their feelings as well
and like just kind of address the
differences within different opinions on
something like today on the topic that
we're going to talk about freedom
um just like everything that's going on
in the world because it is so polarizing
like you said i feel like the media
wants to create this division and
there's no nuance left there's like the
left or the right like you said you're
either all bad or all good and it's it's
like
interesting how the moment you come out
with a differing opinion that they don't
like someone doesn't like it's like oh
then they're all bad with all these
names so well yeah yeah i mean it's
emotional immaturity that's what it is
it's grown people acting like toddlers
right everyone absolutely wanting to get
their way and demonizing and
name-calling anyone who isn't 100 on
board with everything and once people
start playing into that tribal mentality
as well it causes a lot of problems but
one is that it shuts down thinking
right if your notion is that you just
need to go with your tribe or the herd
or your party or whatever it is on
everything even if you disagree or you
have a problem with it or
whatever the case may be
then you just become
a mindless drone right you're you're no
longer thinking for yourself you're it's
what i call outsourcing your thinking
it's just
other people
dictating to you exactly what you're
supposed to think exactly what you're
supposed to believe who you're supposed
to like who you're supposed to dislike
who you're allowed to talk to who you're
not allowed to talk to and to me that's
all that's all nonsense it's all
nonsense i will talk to absolutely
anybody and everybody who wants to talk
to me and who there's any reason to talk
to whether i look we have over seven
billion people in this world there's no
two people on this planet who agree on
everything and the notion that we should
that that would even be the case is is
observed right within a family within a
marriage within friendship groups you
can have the tightest friends what
you have disagreements that's literally
how it is because everyone's an
individual and it sort of blows my mind
that
that isn't the assumption and
expectation right like that's always
been
the case right and you can have a you
can even have a strong disagreement with
someone on multiple things and you can
still absolutely love respect
like
and
honor that person
um you know and you can also have people
who you don't really actually like and
get on with even though on paper maybe
you agree with a lot of things yeah but
in terms of personality or or vibe or
other common interests it's just it's
just not there so i really encourage
people to be individuals themselves and
also to treat other people as
individuals i try my best not to talk
about entire groups of people as if
they're all just that one thing like i'm
i'm not perfect sometimes i will paint
with a broader brush than is necessary
to get
i try not to do more than necessary to
get the point across right um but really
any type of prejudice or bigotry or
anything like that that's really where
it stems from it stems from
painting an entire group of people with
a broad brush this is the root of racism
this is the root of sexism this is the
root of any type of ism or phobia in the
true sense
it's just looking at one characteristic
of a person or a group of people and
then just making a huge jump and just
saying okay all
almost any time you say all x people are
y
you're going to be wrong right almost
every time unless you're saying
something redundant like all
human beings are homo sapiens or
something right yeah you're always going
to be wrong if i say all women are
x
right and x is some
[Music]
trait that is just kind of like a gender
you're always going to be wrong if you
say all white people are ex all black
people are white you're always gonna be
wrong um so i encourage people to kind
of break
break out of that mindset
and i think that's ultimately how you
have a more empathetic society and even
if people have their differences they
can coexist and
it stuff doesn't go totally sideways
totally and people assume that even with
me on my online presence that all of my
friends must think exactly like me and
if something comes out oh ellen thinks
this way they start going to my friends
i can't believe you think this type of
thing like you don't even know if they
think that way and i don't make my
friends based on if we have agree on
everything or even
one in particular big thing that's
important to me a lot of times it is a
foundational starting point that helps
connect you to people but not always
many times my closest friends
we don't agree with many things that i'm
even passionate about but because we get
along because we are open-hearted
listening to each other and respectful
and one thing i really value in a
friendship is openness and honesty and
being willing to just share your real
feelings about things and that's how i
build friendship above all else yeah
absolutely i think if you have friends
then you should be able to talk about
virtually anything
with them i'm always confused by this
notion i mean i always have people
messaging me dming me saying oh you know
i've lost
this many
someone despite knowing you have some
disagreement you they voted for a
different party
or um
in in this situation now people are
losing friends over
freaking vaccines like this person took
a shot and i did like this person won't
take a shot and i was like honestly
right you're putting that you're putting
political party you're putting like
medicines from big pharma you're putting
that over
your long-term relationships over your
own friends your own flesh and blood
like to me that is totally
insane it's totally insane and despite
the fact that i mean i i share my
opinions a lot with the world like
millions and millions of people see the
stuff i put out there and i'm proud to
say that throughout this whole thing
i've lost zero friends that's right zero
friends because we can talk about all
this stuff right there might be
something like man zooby i don't think
you're right on this one i'll be like
man i think you're crazy on this one
right and then we can talk about it we
can laugh we can joke about each other
but ultimately we still respect each
other we still love each other and we
also know that we're operating
from a good place oftentimes
people want the same thing like there
are very few people who wake up in the
world every morning and they think i
want to make the world a worse place
that's very rare right there are
psychopaths that does exist yeah right
it's not something that's non-existent
but it's extraordinarily rare so even
the person who on paper it might look
like
they want something totally different
from you or like their views political
religious whatever are totally different
in most cases people are operating with
the best information they have
in
the way that fits their world view most
people are doing what they think is
right and it's really important to
understand that even if you think
they're totally wrong or they're very
misguided or they just have the wrong
info whatever it is the best way forward
isn't just to call names and demonize
it's actually to have these
conversations so actually when people
are doing this and they're blocking or
uh canceling their their friends or just
people they follow whatever it is in the
real world or or online who don't agree
with them on everything
all they're doing is they're making
their own perspective narrower and
narrower they're increasing the size of
their own blind spots so this is how you
have those situations where something
happens in the world a big thing a big
election right and you have people like
i mean to this day there's still people
like oh my gosh how did trump win in
2016. and i'm like how are you how do
you not know anybody
there's of this 60 million plus people
in your own country who voted you
haven't had that conversation with
anyone and just been like um okay why
did you vote that way
right or why did you vote the other way
like these are just basic conversations
and if you have them even if you leave
in disagreement you'll at least be able
to understand another person's way of
thinking and that's the goal yeah and if
you can't understand the way other
people think at all then that that's
nothing to be proud of some people are
almost proud of the fact that they live
in an echo chamber and i'm like that's
nothing to be proud of you should always
be able to understand the different
perspectives yes for sure yeah and
i think i i think that
like a lot of people might even just the
mere the reason why that they're sure
that they aren't hearing the other side
or why people might be tempted to like
shun their friends who disagree with
them is is because they struggle to have
open-hearted conversations and i think
it comes from maybe the way that they
were raised if they never saw like
parents or respectful figures in their
life have disagreements and and talk and
discuss that type of thing i know i have
friends who were raised that way and so
they struggled when they got older to
just share their opinion without being
afraid of being like shunned by like a
family member or a loved one and i was
raised by my parents to just we could
talk about anything we could disagree
lay it all out there talk it all out so
then when i got older and i'm talking
about this with people who aren't used
to it they're like what are you doing
right now like
we don't talk about this i'm like wait
don't we want to understand why we think
the way that we do like that's the goal
for sure so what made you like
start to talk about these things what
like sh what was there like a pivotal
moment where you're like i need to start
talking about this thing or did it just
happen there actually was yeah
there was because i've been um so i put
out my first album 15 years ago and i've
been online using social media for
a similar amount of time you know back
in the myspace days i was there at the
beginning of facebook so on and so forth
and actually the a big turning point was
in 2018
so i've always talked about all of this
stuff with my friends with my family in
private but especially as a musician and
as a creator i always thought
let me totally stay away publicly from
anything political or
sensitive cultural or social issues let
me
not polarize anybody let me not rock the
boat as they say let me just keep that
private and i'll just talk about music
and other stuff that is out there
for me
there was a so all through 2015 and 2016
i was
really really just watching what was
going on in the world and i was feeling
a little bit concerned about various
things that were happening particularly
in the anglosphere in the usa canada
australia uk i was just seeing a rising
tide of
a lot of stuff that i'm in opposition of
a lot of bad ideas
and i was seeing this popping up and i
was seeing other people
podcasters
people on youtube talking about a lot of
these things and i was following like i
very much very closely followed the rise
of say someone like jordan peterson from
his opposition to bill c-16 to him
becoming this giant global figure i was
following lots of guys you know the joe
rogan dave rubin people who they used to
call the intellectual dark web all of
that i was very interested in what was
going on there and then in 2018 actually
i don't know if i've told this story
before but there was um
a guy i actually know who was the
president of this of a student union of
one of the universities in the uk
and
he's uh he's like a super social justice
warrior type and uh he posts a lot of
annoying stuff on facebook but i tend to
just ignore it and sort of laugh but
there was something he he wrote about
how he supports free speech
but
people shouldn't be allowed to say
things that are offensive or something
like that yeah and i i felt compelled to
comment on this one because i was like
that does not make any sense and this is
coming from someone who's got a high
position in a university and i think
that's a very
concerning way for someone in that
position to be thinking trying to shut
that down right especially given that
offense is totally subjective
so i responded i can't remember exactly
what i said but i said something like
you you either you support free speech
or you don't like you've written a
contradiction here um and then we we
kind of got into this uh we kind of got
into this back and forth on facebook
where it was also interesting because
most of his followers
he was kind of trying to bring them in
to back him up and actually they were
all siding with me
because my point made more sense and
they were like yeah actually zooby's
right
um anyway
after a lot of back and forth this
conversation ended with him saying that
pretty much quoting word for word people
like zooby have dangerous ideas that get
people killed
and he shouldn't be allowed on
university campuses wow
and i was
like okay this is where we are we're at
a position where somebody thinks i'm
i'm a very reasonable sane rational guy
i'm not some crazy radical right let
alone someone with ideas that get people
killed right so i was like whoa okay
this is going really really far
right if this is the current climate in
universities
then
more people need to speak so i think
from that point onward that sort of
snapped something in my brain and i was
just like i started tweeting way more
aggressively
like it's time to talk about this yeah i
was like look
there's two because i wasn't seeing my
views voiced very much in the public
discussion i was like no one is saying
the stuff i'm thinking so just like now
a lot of people like and follow what i
do because they're like man zoopy you're
saying you say what i think
right and i was kind of feeling like man
not a lot of people are saying what i'm
thinking so
i can't outsource this to anybody else
i've got to do it i need to kind of jump
into the fray a little bit and so i
started doing that and it really started
resonating because another big thing is
i never knew
my thoughts and the way i
i articulate them was particularly
unique or special mm-hmm right like
seems normal yeah i think i'm pretty
sane and reasonable and irrational and
i'm not coming out with some huge
crazy ideas or something um but common
sense in the age we live in is actually
very uncommon let alone the ability to
articulate it in a clear way so i
started doing that and that really
started to grow my followers a lot more
and i started to get specifically quite
a lot of attention from the usa
and then early 2019 i had a that viral
tweet where i
identified as a woman and i did the
deadlift and that blew up online and
millions of people discovered me off the
back of that
and that just took things on a different
trajectory and from then on i started
getting invited onto a lot of major
podcasts and tv appearances and this and
that and
it went from my audience primarily just
being in the uk and knowing me from
music to my audience being global and
knowing me yes for my music but also
as a
public thinker to some degree i guess i
don't really know what to call it to put
words uh in a way that helps people to
be able to be like yeah this is what i'm
thinking that maybe they had a hard time
putting into words yeah just trying to
make sense of the world that's really
how i've been since i was a child i've
always been very inquisitive and i've
always been someone who doesn't really
doesn't succumb to peer pressure and is
willing to go against the herd and
willing to
be the odd one out in the room whatever
it is i'm just trying to understand
the world so even what i do what i'm
doing right now is i'm thinking out loud
yeah it's the same thing i do on my
social media i'm just thinking out loud
sometimes i've really thought it through
and i'm presenting an idea which is
ninety percent through on thinking other
times i just have a question i'm like ah
what do you what do you guys think of
this or put it out there yeah here's an
idea what do you think of this or how
about that whatever and i just do that i
just do that publicly
and people find it compelling and
engaging so okay so on that note let's
get into the topic of freedom okay let's
go
where do we even start
what are your thoughts let's go the
mandates i mean i feel like it's
important to bring up what
maybe another opposing side is to what
you're thinking and just kind of address
that so like people who are you know
liking the mandates liking the way
things have been handled
by
our politicians and government elected
officials
um they might look at i mean you haven't
shared anything yet on this podcast how
you feel but like they might look at
someone who's against the mandates and
wanting things to go back to normal
saying that they're selfish and
like that they don't trust the science
yeah so what do you have to say that um
look at firstly everyone's entitled to
their opinion
um i am
a pro
liberty person i'm a pro individual
rights person i'm a pro personal
responsibility person that doesn't
magically change just because there's
a virus going around which by the way
has a over 99
survival rate in the vast majority of
the population um that's not i don't
believe we should jettison all of our
freedoms and
basic rights
uh over that or discriminate against
people based on it or said create new
lines of segregation in society based on
it all of that is nonsense all i
advocate for is what everybody claimed
to believe back in january 2020 that's
all
all that's happened is i haven't changed
my position
and
a lot of other people have and they've
become
they've been swept into authoritarianism
um
i mean if you were to go back to january
2020 and you would even propose some of
the notions that people are now
advocating for
they themselves
would
be mortified can you imagine yeah they
themselves would be mortified but over
the course of 18 19 months whatever it's
been now
people have been systematically and i
would argue strategically
propagandized and brainwashed to
actually become
way more radical and to give up their
own freedoms there's nothing radical
about saying people should be allowed to
make their own basic decisions about
whether or not they go outside or who
they talk to or whether or not they can
hug their friends and family or if they
need to wear a mask in their business or
yes or wear a mess if you want to wear a
mask that's up to you i've never
throughout this whole thing said people
should not be allowed to wear masks if
you want to wear masks you should be up
to totally you want to take a shot it's
up to you you want to do this you want
to do that that is
up to you right now i know that there
will be someone who is listening and
thinking oh but you know this is a
communicable disease this is something
that can spread etc i understand that
it's also that's also not new we've been
living with diseases and viruses and
illness
throughout our entire lives and prior to
our lives and the notion that you would
shut down society or force businesses to
close or take kids out of school for a
year
over a flu for example
would be absurd right and talk speaking
of the flu people hate it when you
compare this virus to the flu yeah right
but firstly they're in the same family
secondly the flu is statistically more
dangerous to children than this is
that's just a fact like 100 yeah so it
would logically make more sense to do
all of this and have all of this
hysteria when it comes to the younger
population
over a flu than with this one and
especially at this stage it's just you
know everyone who wants to
everyone who wants to take the vax has
already had it
those who don't
don't want it but we're just in this
position where
politicians have grasped a lot of power
and
i'm someone who's just highly skeptical
of the government because i know
historian because i see what's going on
around the world
and i knew from early on that once they
seized that power it's going to be very
difficult for them to relinquish it
they're not going to want to
and when you think of all the different
incentives from profit to control to
power
i mean i don't believe someone could
disagree with me on this but at this
stage and early on i don't believe this
has
anything to do with health or saving
lives or taking care of people i i don't
believe that i have there's so many
points
that make it clear especially at this
stage that that is not what's going on
right and so
that is how i view it like i said i'm
open to conversation if people are like
no you know this is just about health
and about safety
people are entitled to have that
viewpoint but the problem is see my my
view is not infringing on anyone what i
advocate for doesn't infringe on anybody
right i've said from day one look if
you're scared or you're vulnerable
whether that is
logical or illogical to me that doesn't
matter right if you want to stay at home
for the next five years and you want to
wear three masks and you don't want to
go outside i support your right to do
that right if you don't want to run your
business or you don't want to go to work
or you want to do this or you want to
you can do what you want right i don't i
don't care that's up to you but to force
everybody else to try to be as afraid of
you
as afraid as you or to try to force
everybody else to to go along with all
this or literally get to the point
you're trying to force people to inject
things into their body because you're
scared i mean it doesn't even it doesn't
even make sense logically it does it
doesn't even make sense so this is what
happens when people are in panic mode
and hysteria is they start saying things
and doing things and advocating for
things that do not make any sense and
simply by throwing out the word science
people think you can just do nonsense
and say the word science and magically
it makes sense
and it doesn't right there's been so
much anti-scientific irrational nonsense
going on all over the world for the past
18 months now
um
and it just continues and it's like
i think due to people wanting to protect
their own egos and due to cognitive
dissonance and the sunk cost fallacy
very few people want to look up and go
um maybe i should reevaluate the
situation is all this new information
has come out and the situation now is
very different to where it was say in
february 2020 maybe
maybe there's something else going on
here maybe i haven't got the whole
picture maybe those people i thought
were crazy are not so crazy um maybe
it's me being selfish
people calling everyone else selfish is
that oh actually maybe it's selfish of
me to try to
make all these
other demands on other people because
i'm afraid you know um so that's my
that's kind of my my risk my response
to people who think more along those
lines because i'm like look i'm
supporting your rights you're trying to
take away my and everybody else's so
i'm literally fighting for your own
rights for your own freedom for your own
liberty that you always had before yeah
that's all there's so much to say there
because i think a lot of people don't
know history and how it does repeat
itself whereas some people are focusing
more on that and thinking about what
what is coming next type of thing and i
do agree with you that this overall the
overall sentiment is not about our
health um if it was there would be a lot
different information that would be
being shared but i do think that like
the healthcare worker workers and
doctors and um people who consider
themselves who or who are considered
experts who are advocating for a lot of
things like social distancing and
masking and still doing that i do think
that they do believe in they do believe
in what they're saying and maybe and
like you said maybe there needs to be
some re-evaluation and
like listening to all sides of the
spectrum and i think one thing that
really concerned me from the very
beginning which i even said in the very
beginning in like uh something online
and instagram post was that i feel i
mean we know that all of these mandates
weren't they never considered the
detrimental effects of doing them
because never in the history
of the world have we ever done this like
maybe they don't care
yeah i mean were you were you
quarantined the healthy that has never
happened before and
um it wasn't discussed at all online the
increase in suicide rates the increase
in stress um that could affect um heart
attacks and all different kinds of
factors that just wasn't considered at
all an abuse abuse abuse going up in
homes
there's infinite factors yeah there's
infinite factors financial economic
physical health mental health um impact
on children impact on poverty like it's
it's gigantic i said more than a year
ago that the the response is going to
kill more people than the virus and i
still i don't know exactly how you'd
measure that but i still
think that is true right and
this is and also look here's another
conversation that was never had who's
who decided that who decided that this
virus is the most important thing in the
world
who did that who decided that this one
particular virus amongst all the ones we
have and everything else that matters
from liberty to freedom to people being
happy to people being able to live
right who
who decided that's that's a
philosophical question right all these
nations have
assumed everything is running under the
assumption that the most important thing
in the world is
reducing the number or minimizing the
number of people who die from the rona
well the people who decided were the
medical experts within our governments
and they are not experts when it comes
to social work when it comes to suicide
when it comes to
also
that's not
how policy should even should even work
totally right so even if you have got a
doctor or a scientist or actual medical
experts right they can inform on that
but that doesn't mean that
philosophically you change the whole
found the whole foundation and structure
of a nation
right yeah where oh actually
like who like literally to take take two
things okay liberty versus reducing the
risk of death from a given virus right
which one is which one is more important
right and is there a scale is it a
binary or is it is it a scale whatever
right
i would argue liberty is far more
important right right by holding
upholding human rights
and dignity and freedom
is more important than
minimizing
or attempting to minimize or creating an
illusion that you're minimizing um death
or hospitalization i would say almost
from
from almost anything in fact right and
the other side is
you know when it comes to understanding
and listening to the other people's
opinions is saying that you know you
don't care about grandma and you only
care about economics emotional blackmail
yeah and i but i really do believe that
at their heart they really do think the
latter or the the first thing you said
is more important and maybe that just
comes from
um
where you're getting your information
and like like you said you're you're
looking into history you see what's
happened in our past about you know how
america came to be even even though
you're not american you look at that and
our founding fathers and what they
fought for and how important freedom was
because of what happens when you lose
your freedoms that we as a society
haven't seen in our lifetime yeah well
people are seeing it now yeah right um
people are seeing it now and again this
is the thing it's like look if you're
scared you can stay home
if you're scared you can wear a mask
forever like you've always been able to
do that why do you think there's so much
confusion still
still because the media has destroyed
people's brains and ability to think
people have been
literally we've had over 500 days of
straight propaganda
all over the world on a global level
every almost every city in every country
and every continent around the world
people have just been hammered
hammered hammered hammered with fear and
propaganda and when people are afraid
they do not think rationally
you're much more willing to give up your
freedoms if you're afraid yes people
succumb to people don't just
people don't just
accept authoritarianism they demand it
and what about people who just don't
think that it's propaganda they don't
they think that the government has our
best interest at heart and even the
media or maybe i think a lot of people
actually pay more attention well yeah i
actually think most people think the
mainstream media news is is like
you know there's a lot of problems with
it and that there's a lot of corruption
and yet at the same time they still have
so much power over what we think it's
it's double think you know and look
nobody is totally immune to cognitive
errors
right nobody is like the perfect clear
rational thinker yeah right and emotion
is a thing an emotion should be a thing
but emotion alone is a terrible way to
drive
policy
and to
create
like the foundation and structure of how
things should generally
work right you don't want people to be
absolutely cold hard ruthless and
emotionless
but when emotion takes over everything
and it takes over and it supersedes
logic and it supersedes reason and it
supersedes proportionality
um then you're in a you're then in a
moral panic you're in a collective
hysteria and we're in a collective
hysteria we're living through a moral
panic that i've certainly in my lifetime
never experienced before i think this is
the first huge one in several decades
actually i think we've had things on
smaller scales such as with terrorism i
think that was a little bit of a moral
panic and we've had other ones but not
like this not involving so many people
on such a global
systematic scale with the same messaging
and the same brainwashing and all of
that going on we're essentially living
in a time now where people are
living in different realities there's
different realities and you see this
they've even done surveys and polls
where
they're talking about um
where they're talking about
how what people think the the
hospitalization rates are or what the
death rates are etcetera and people are
out some people are out by a factor of a
thousand
right they think that if you get this
virus that there's a fifty percent
chance that you're going to end up in
hospital it doesn't even matter how old
you are or how old you are there's
people who think that man you know if
you get this there's people who still
think that the death rate is like five
percent or even 10 or something yeah
right and
so
if you view it through that way i can
understand and empathize with
why
they're so afraid and are kind of been
going haywire for such a long period of
time but it's like
they're not looking at the data and the
stats correctly they're not in fact in
many cases they're not even looking at
them right they're just running with
what they feel or they're running with
personal anecdote right look because
this here's the thing right you know of
course i'm not because some people again
this is a false binary some people will
be like listening oh my gosh this guy
doesn't think covet exists right it's
like look it exists it's there right
there's a virus but there's something
called proportionality so to upend the
entire world
up in an entire country put millions and
millions of people out of work rip
hundreds of millions of kids away from
school create all these mental health
issues all these physical health issues
create all of this the economic fallout
the inflation the unemployment all of
this stuff over literally
a virus i'm going to repeat with an over
99.9 survival rate in most of the
population for which there are various
treatments available and that they have
got the uh
um
[Music]
i'll call them vaccines because that's
what they call them but i think they're
more like therapeutics um
it's absurd right and people need to
just
breathe in and breathe out and think
okay hang on what are we doing does this
does this make sense is this
proportional and is the hysteria and the
response
justified i would say a strong no i
would have said a strong no more than a
year ago and especially at this stage uh
for me it's a it's a an even stronger no
and i think that people are i think
people are asleep walking into i think
people have sleep walked into tyranny in
many places well because it's like
taking a little bit of your freedoms
away at a time and they're just seeing
how much they can get away with
but yeah totally but i have friends who
kind of look at it like well why would
they have us do all these things if they
didn't have like if they have they
should they must have their best our
best interest at heart i think that that
comes from just seeing the people in
their real lives the people at their
work you know like maybe you're in the
medical device field and you're like no
one in my field wants people to die no
one you know no one wants to enforce
things or make things happen that um
that would cause harm so when you see
your real life experience you think of
course our elected officials have our
best interest at heart and um it really
comes down to like a different uh
perspective on the potentialness of
overstepping yes
look anyone
just look at the 20th century let's just
look at the last hundred years right
anyone who can look at the last hundred
years and come to the conclusion that
the government always has the people's
best interest in mind
is
naive or stupid like i i don't like
calling people stupid but you can't look
at the 20th century whether you're
talking about the rise of hitler and
nazism to mao in china
to um pinochet to
stalin to paul pott to all of these
dictators in the middle east and africa
et cetera saddam hussein right how can
you come to the conclusion that the
government governments always have best
people's interest in mind oh absolute
nonsense right you know you're in fact
factually that's not an opinion that's
factually incorrect i mean i naively my
whole life thought we're past this we're
past all the horribleness that have
happened in the world i really did i was
like there's no way something like a
holocaust or slavery in like a more
developed nation would happen again like
we're totally passed all the hardships
within a country and then this happened
and i'm like oh this is the thing in our
lifetime this is the this is the thing
well people forget that we're still
living through history
right people think that history is over
right yeah history is over freedom won
there's no more
dictators there's no more best i mean
come on north korea still exists guys
um so
it's that it's honestly it's uh
it's complacency and it's it's great
that
in the modern west you know it's been
such a long time it's been several
decades since we've really had
you know i mean like a real severe war
whether it's a world war one or world
war ii or even vietnam i'm sure there
have been wars in our lifetime
but not in the way that
generations before us used to deal with
so it's easy to look at the situation
and think oh we're here now and
that you think things just
keep going forward right i imagine if
you went back to 1921
in 1921 people thought that hey we're so
modern we're so sophisticated yeah we're
not we're not like these brutes
back in history who are committing
genocide and always going to war and
doing all this nonsense right like do
you think that the germans back in 1921
were there like oh yeah like this is
going to happen in the next couple of
course not nobody
saw it coming and it's so important and
for people to understand that we are not
fundamentally different to our ancestors
we are the same people we have not
evolved you don't think we've evolved no
not at all i kind of i tend to think
that like that like through
like all the hardship and the barbaric
stuff that has happened there's like
these little moments of clarity on how
to be
more loving and more um kind and then
like raising your children that way and
i kind of feel like over time that's how
like nations have gotten better and what
we fought for but then we just can't get
lazy to think that it could never happen
again yeah so i i agree with you to an
extent so
we are more enlightened than our
ancestors because we can look back at
their errors and mistakes yeah right
that's the value of knowing history
because you can look back at it and you
can oh let's not do that again that was
a bad idea right that's why so right now
as we speak in various states cities and
countries they're rolling out this
concept of vaccine passports show your
papers to enter a grocery store a
restaurant a gym a cinema whatever
we've done segregation before it's a bad
idea such a bad idea you had it in the
usa you had jim crow laws you had it in
uh south africa even within our lifetime
apartheid right
when you create a two-tier society and
you give certain rights and privileges
and access to own to one group and
another one who is unclean you don't
give it's always a bad idea always i
mean that's kind of how they started
with nazi germany yes labeling the
jewish people as um the ability that
they unclean that they spread spread
diseases and by slowly just implementing
this over and over and over again people
hear it and the more that they hear
something unfortunately like you said
most people don't they outsource their
thinking as opposed to true critical
thinking the masses started to believe
it yeah and it preys on people's worst
tendencies right so now you i've seen
people openly saying
that
even even some mainstream people saying
that if someone is unvaccinated against
uh against the
covid and they get it then they should
they should be denied healthcare
yeah right
sorry to anyone who does not like
holocaust comparisons but this is how
you end up in those type of situations
right and
this is that level of demonization and
dehumanization or
you know calling other people diseased
viewing people as an existential threat
it's such a dark road i mean literally
comedians are now making jokes about it
it's not funny you know it's it's this
is the this is the problem and
this is what i mean when i say human
beings haven't involved right because we
still have those
base
primal tribalism yeah i see what you
mean yeah once you start that's why it's
dangerous to see people as enemies
because once you do what do you do with
an enemy what do you do with the threat
you exterminate it
right that is literally how human beings
are
wired and it's so foolish and naive for
people to think that all the bad stuff
that has happened in history
cannot happen again totally and by
recognizing that it can happen again
that's how you stop it yeah from
happening again right all of us
especially when we were younger would
always look i mean you just again just
look at the 20th century like how did
they how did they let that happen like
that doesn't make sense like i know were
they all like how you know how to and
now it's i mean i'm i certainly don't
ask those questions anymore because i
can see how it happens it's very slow
yeah it's it's incremental but it can
also happen fast i mean it's only 18
months the world has been upended in 18
months previously free countries yeah so
really not that slow look at canada look
at australia look at new zealand look at
italy look at um
uh slovenia right certain parts of the
world which were just
free and open some of these countries
i've been to before and traveled to is
all lovely whatever
it's like man i'm not stepping foot
there right now
because they're
they're going crazy and
people in power get drunk off of
power
and
like i think i think a lot of people
don't
i think most people never really
experience power so they don't really
know
how
corrupting it can
it can be when that is unchecked and the
truth is that a lot of people in in
government
are power hungry they're power seekers
right how why why do you even want to be
a president or a prime minister or a
governor or a mayor or whatever it is
it's because you seek power
you seek power so
you're gonna get a higher level
sure like most people you know in the
normal world would be you know decent
and friendly and the ones who want to
become yeah but they're not the ones who
want to be you know ellen fisher does
not want to be president of the usa no
right you do a better job in my opinion
but you're too you don't want that type
of power you don't want to flex power
over 300 million
people so the people who tend to get
into those positions
are you know
at best they might not you know
they're kind of kept in check but
oftentimes and this this is why every
i mean has there ever been like a good
dictatorship
right is it possible that every single
person who's ever reached the position
of dictator is just a horrible evil
psychopath
probably not
they just have totally unchecked power
to do whatever
they want and have no one hold them
accountable i think unfortunately a lot
of people don't realize this because
they know people who work in the
government and they see look at how like
they're a public servant they really
have our best interests at heart because
most people do i think
it's really just the few a few at the
very top that have a lot of power that's
not to say anyone who has power is this
way it's just we have to be careful we
have to be careful yeah to look at our
history and realize how important
freedom is and i i hate that there's
such a broad stroke here that like
inevitably it's like oh look at these
two here there must be these like
gun-loving flag toning in the middle of
the street wrong with gun-toting and
flag flag flag not at all no let me be
clear but the way that it's
it's projected that anyone who like
questions mandates or lockdowns or masks
or vaccines like or a specific vaccine
even not even all vaccines but even just
one specific one you're automatically
lumped in this category that you must be
a trumpian you must be all these things
and it's unfortunate because it doesn't
leave any room for the gray that you can
just
let's just find
how many different levels of different
opinions about from left to right that
there is
so yeah i would also i would also
encourage anyone who is
you know maybe feeling triggered by
something i've said here
is to think back in
go go
back literally just two years ago and
think
if
you
if someone had proposed
all of this stuff that is going on now
right especially in places where they've
been very authoritarian with it right if
someone had suggested that
you know healthy people should be forced
to stay at home businesses forced to
shut down children taken out of school
for a year for a virus that isn't even
killing them um people should be forced
to be injected against their will or
lose their job
um people should be forced to cover
their faces
in the west even outside in some places
you would have like you would have you
would have said absolutely not i don't
support that whether you're liberal
you're conservative you people everyone
would have said no no not in the west
this isn't china we don't roll like that
so what has happened in less than two
years time that has made
you know perhaps the listener or so many
other people
totally change their principles
right
yeah it's the amount of deaths and coven
and everything that's happened based on
what is being said on the news and by
experts that we trust you know yeah well
the experts have been lying to you for
over 18 months so maybe if someone keeps
lying to you over and over and over
again you should perhaps trust them less
and perhaps you should just look at the
data and the statistics for your self
and
work it out from there sure maybe you
look at the data and the statistics and
you still come to
certain conclusions
um but i would just encourage people to
think i'm not big on telling people
exactly what to think i want people to
think though right
i want people to think because a lot of
people are not thinking yeah and what's
really frustrating to me is how many
people are in support of censoring
censoring like physicians with different
opinions so that's a reason why we're
thinking it's one specific narrative
about covet and that is one specific
opinion and let's look at that and let's
hear this this perspective but i also
want to hear this other perspective that
has a chance that's like going to
challenge that viewpoint and
unfortunately when something really like
um an important speech comes out by an
expert a physician a scientist pull it
off youtube it's pulled off youtube and
there's so many people who support this
and i'm like how how can you support
this because one day they're going to
come after you you who thinks that
anyone who disagrees with you you need
to censor them because it's you know
killing people one day you're going to
say something that you really believe is
right and they're going to censor you
and they're going to say you're the one
who's hurting people yeah and and to use
your their own argument that is there's
nothing more anti-scientific
than not being allowed to ask questions
science is based on inquiry questioning
science is science if you can't question
it it's not science it's dogma
right even within a religion
which some people especially critics of
religion would say is a form of dogma
you can ask questions
right if you have a pastor or a priest
or an imam or
um
you know any other
spiritual or religious leader who is
saying you should be able to ask them
questions
right and the response shouldn't just be
all right we're going to silence you or
shut up or you're stupid or you're going
to hell or oh your auntie whatever
it should be answering the question i
don't trust any expert or scientist so
called who is not willing to entertain
questions and challenge i don't trust a
single one right if you are an expert in
something or you're knowledgeable about
something you should always be open to
question and challenge right if there's
something i've said on this podcast that
you someone disagrees with or whatever
i should be open to
them going hey hang on what did you say
there it didn't make sense or this is my
thought or whatever if i'm just like
nope silence block block block science
then what does that say about how i feel
yeah about what i'm saying right because
good ideas can stand up against
challenge and scrutiny and in science
especially in medicine especially in
medicine that has to be for sure
possible once you start shutting down
questions and shutting down even from
experts and you're shutting this down
you're shutting potential treatments
down whatever it is you've literally
moved into the realm of
fundamentalist religion not even like
like radical yeah
no questions allowed burn the heretic at
the stake like that's what you've moved
into and that is not that's not science
that's not reason and actually that is
what gets people killed because
throughout history
you know science doesn't run based on
consensus just because a majority of
people think something at one point does
not mean it's
correct we've been wrong so many times
and wrong so many times when they said
smoking was okay for pregnant women yeah
doctors doctors were pushing it right
and and so this is the thing there's a
level of corruption and there's also
just a level of incompetence and just
not knowing it's okay not to know things
right it's okay not to know things and
i'll tell you two phrases i've never
heard i've pretty much never heard
throughout this past 18 months from any
public official or any expert i've never
heard someone say we were wrong
oh my gosh yeah and i've never almost
and and i've i've heard it but i very
rarely heard someone say i don't know or
we're not sure what did they say the
science changed mm-hmm nonsense science
doesn't change right like what people
understand of it does like facts facts
are facts we realized we were wrong yeah
and this is the thing right if they if
throughout the communication through
this whole thing's been a disaster if
people have said like look we don't know
but based on what we know at the time
this is what we think if you change your
mind
it should be like this is why we've
changed our mind we looked at this this
data came out and so we're changing our
position that would be so much more
intellectually it would all be that
would all be fine it'd be so much easier
to take them seriously too exactly and
then you could trust people if someone
if they say like look let's take
something simple take the masks
in
like
march april may maybe even june last
year
the experts in multiple countries
literally explicitly said don't wear
masks masks don't work
essentially yeah right and by the way
masks are not new technology we've had
these for decades and they were never
recommended in flu seasons etc for a
reason um
and then they flipped the script and
just said
not just everybody should wear a mask
but they create created a mandate to try
to force people to wear masks even
children even children
outside they never explained why right
when people say oh the science changes
like what what what science what
specifically
changed what were what was the real
world information that was coming out or
like the the proper studies not just
spraying aerosols onto
mannequins or whatever nonsense they did
what what was the real
thing that changed here that's led to
this u-turn right and
they didn't even try to explain it
they've done this with so many things
they just changed things and then say oh
the science changed and it's like
where it adds to that was the
explanation for sure yeah and you know
this and it reaches the point where
and this this is where i differ with
some people because was it hanlon's
razor where they say you know never put
down to malice what can be attributed to
stupidity or incompetence but um you
know
when when it seems like there's a
contradiction maybe people need to check
their premises
right because whatever a lot of people
say man you know this doesn't make sense
this doesn't make sense and it's like
look if i view this through the lens of
profit power and control everything
makes sense if you view it through the
lens of health science safety reasonable
thinking saving lives etc a lot of stuff
doesn't it ceases to make sense so there
comes a point where and this is not me
saying that like everybody or even most
people
are have any sort of intent i do agree
that most people do have good positive
intent but i do think that there are
people pulling the strings
who do have ill intent and i think that
some of the repercussions of the
policies as you were saying some of
those downstream repercussions i
struggle to believe it's all accidental
right i struggle to believe it's all
accidental because i don't think you can
be that incompetent across all these
different countries that you you've just
caused all of this chaos and damage that
was very easily predictable
right and you oh you you genuinely
didn't see that that was going to happen
of of course it was going to happen but
what about like the lower elected
officials like for instance like the
mayor here in maui we recently well it's
all of hawaii but
in maui so we recently started vaccine
mandates the health pass so-called to
get into restaurants bars and gyms um
for so long it was you had to wear a
mask outside
on the beach they're telling tourists as
they come here you need to wear it on
the beach and we're sitting on the beach
i'm just looking at everyone wearing a
mask i'm like what are we doing what are
we doing here no science no logic no
rationale you can't spread a disease you
don't have and this doesn't spread
outside to begin i think a lot of people
are just
afraid there's a lot of fear there's
fear of the virus there's fear of
speaking out with your opinion if you
have a different opinion than the status
quo
um there's fear of not being able to see
your loved ones and having discussions
with your family there's so much fear
and fear drives a lot of it
unfortunately something you said about
um
being able to have your beliefs
challenged online
it's really not just online but just in
general but it's diff it's so difficult
online because you can't there's people
who are responding have like a nominee
and like it's and i just it's so
difficult to be misunderstood i've said
this in a past episode for me i i really
don't like being misunderstood but i
also don't have the time to like go back
and forth in a comment online that's why
these in-person conversations are so
wonderful to me and that's like one of
the main reasons why i started a podcast
yeah i'm glad you did i mean i've just
accepted that some people are going to
misunderstand and misunderstand me
misinterpret me uh sometimes inevitable
sometimes unintentionally often times
intentionally and maliciously um and
i've just accepted that so everything oh
no go ahead yeah and it's i'm very
similar in that you know i don't i hate
seeing my name being slandered or
someone misinterpreting what i'm saying
or totally missing the point whatever
but i can address some of it i can't
address all of it and i've just made
peace with that and i'm like look
there's going to be some people even
with this podcast there's going to be
some people maybe who listen to the
first five minutes and they're like oh
this guy's an he's an anti-vaxxer and a
conspiracy theorist and he wants people
to die and what it's like okay god bless
you man like i wish you'd like listen
through with a little more nuance and
get out your feelings but there's people
who are just like that and it's gonna
fall on deaf ears sometimes so i've just
made peace with that and i focus on
those who
choose to listen yeah attention it
there's inevitable and i've said this
before where like the ones who are upset
or have negative really nasty things to
say they seem like so much just because
they're louder it's not like there's
more of them it's a small percentage i
have such a wonderful audience listening
here everyone listening thank you for
listening to our conversation
um one thing i want to ask like or
something we can talk on is like if
coercion is freedom so they might be
saying oh no you still have your
freedoms you can just choose not to go
to the restaurant
you can just choose not to work the job
that you do you know like these
ultimatums some people think it's still
freedom it's fascism so how do you how
do how do we break that down to like
make it make sense that it's that's not
freedom go back to 2019
what was what what was required for you
to participate in free society and not
be discriminated against right what were
the what were they what were the
preconditions for that
existing yeah yeah so
again what's changed i wonder if the
people who
are happy with how everything has been
handled if they think that it should be
handled like this forever like because
viruses are always going to be around
and there's going to be another big
virus or do they think that like this
virus is the only virus that's going to
be this bad and then we can be done oh
there's definitely going to be worse
ones in the future yeah no question
no question i mean this thing's mild
compared to any previous pandemic
like on scale and i i'm not saying this
to uh dismiss anybody who has been
uh hospitalized let alone died with it
right every single death is sad and
unfortunate
but if we're comparing this to
say the spanish flu or the black death
anything like that
it's not even in the world
of the level of severity naughty not
even cl like it would be embarrassing
it's kind of embarrassing to even
compare them um and so again just like
humanity continues there's going to
viruses aren't going anywhere yeah
disease is not going anywhere um so
probability wise there's absolutely
going to be something worse yeah that
comes in the future and it and if people
keep
you know there's an elephant in the room
we haven't even discussed here which is
people uh you know not maintaining good
health to begin with yeah which is a big
reason as to why certain countries
have been hit harder with this specific
virus because it does target people with
comorbidities it does particularly
affect people who are overweight or
obese so on and so forth
and um
and of course you know there's been a
huge message missing throughout all the
communities yeah it's like it's like
very little mentioned but you know that
this is not about our health because if
it was like you said we know it's not
if it was it would everything wouldn't
be about staying inside isolating or not
being around family not being around
people you love and like nothing about
taking care of your health at all when
we know without a shadow of a doubt that
that does affect your absolute reaction
to how strong of a reaction you're going
to have to this virus yeah which is why
i struggle to give the people who make
these policies
uh much wiggle room and assumption of
that oh you know they they care about
health and so there's so many things
that would have been so different
if this were primarily genuinely about
getting people in better health and
keeping them safe and
public health and safety
so many things would have been so
different so different so so so
different so i have to assume at some
point that okay there is
ulterior motive here there are other
intentions here um and i know why people
don't like to do that and i know people
don't like being labeled conspiracy
theorists people don't like being called
names whatever
i understand that but i'd rather be
considered that than to
be
manipulated like a sheep into
tyranny right and to end up in some kind
of slave state where i now
all of a sudden have less rights and
freedoms than i did a year and a half
ago even a year ago
right like the people are literally
look
there's no way someone can claim that
the situation right now
is worse than it was a year ago but
somehow
people have less freedom yeah when they
did a year ago how wait how does that
show down shouldn't it shouldn't it get
better like even if even if say
there was going to be a lockdown and
restrictions and this and that
shouldn't it
shouldn't it get freer
over time
now now in some places it has but in
others they've doubled down triple down
quadrupled down to the point where now
despite the threat
massively being
uh mitigated
somehow people are now
stuck with less freedom
than they had even a year ago which is
utter insanity so again people need to
need to check the premises on these
things
yeah i think that
um a lot of positive intentions oh did
you have something to say no no i was
going to say sorry i get a little fired
up on this topic because it genuinely
angers me um what's been happening to in
in many places not everywhere
some places are way better than others
and i'm blessed to have been able to
travel a lot over the past 18 months
despite this
but seeing what's going on in certain
places really it's really upsetting it
really angers me yeah it really angers
me it's really upsetting and i pause
because i'm like i i want to come
together so badly i want us to all like
just try to see where each other is
coming from and positive intention or
positive thought people even friends of
mine
are like well this it's only going to be
temporary this vaccine passport
but i really believe like once you give
up your power you do not give it back
they do not give it back
yeah i mean they started people look
people this started with two weeks to
slow the spread and flatten the curve
yeah or that's not 500 days
don't forget how this started yeah yeah
i mean i made a tweet on twitter that
the hardest part is the slowest spread
is the first 500 days you have such good
tweets anyone who doesn't follow him on
twitter you need to go follow zoobee on
twitter yeah but be prepared for
triggering um
this is the thing the goal posts have
been moved so many times yeah right
people just wake up wake up please yeah
because you could be sleep walking into
a world where you your children your
children's children have
less freedom
than
you ever did yeah i read something about
that that was like you know we're
getting to a place where like your
children's children are gonna not know
the freedom that their grandparents had
that's like really heartbreaking to me
oh man another thing that's crazy is
people are being enslaved by technology
right so people always think of
technology you know primarily as a good
thing that moves society forward but
this whole response everything we're
talking about this wouldn't have even
been possible 20 years ago i know
you if this happened in 2001 there would
probably been a freak out for three to
four weeks and then it would just be
like all right we need to get back to
normal right because you can't just sit
at home and order uber eats and tell
people to work from home and tell kids
to do zoom you know zoom
calls classes none of that stuff means
anything right i mean it's part of why
if you look at a continent like africa
um for the most part vast majority of
countries like
they can't even do this response this
the response we've had in the west is a
luxury it's enabled by technology you
can't just tell
you know hundreds of millions of people
who need to go out and physically work
to earn a living totally and have their
kids go to physically to school you
can't just tell them i'll just stay home
for stay home for eight months
and order your
fast food online and do like they
haven't even got internet let alone
stable electricity
so that's another really interesting
point is that our own technology is
getting to a stage where it's could
enslave us right and that's what that's
really interesting to think about yeah
that is the next risk the next form of
authoritarianism has come and is coming
in the form of
science and technology
yeah and i actually want to do an entire
podcast breakdown about like social
media and kids like it's astounding to
me how many children have their own
smartphones like children children and
access to information that could be very
damaging to their brain development
um
i think about how hard high school was
even without social media just imagine
like what it is today it's very like
black mirror-ish have you ever seen that
show i have unfortunately that show i
know it's every time i always feel
really i love it but it's it's a little
too realistic i love it i love it and
hate it like at the end i'm like why did
i watch that i feel terrible now
but okay i wanted i want to talk a
little bit about your tweets you've had
you've had a lot of viral tweets one of
these ones
that went really viral was your 20
things i've learned or had confirmed
about humanity during the pandemic
and i just want to read some of like my
most interesting ones to me that you
said it's all really fascinating what
you said but number one most people
would rather be in the majority
than be right and that is so true we've
looked at like social experiments and
how quickly we adapt to just like blend
in
not everybody but the majority are like
that even there's like the one i was
starting to tell you but we got
interrupted by the kids which i still
gotta find it to show you where
um a woman sitting in a waiting room and
they're like the the social experiments
to see like how she reacts and this
other guy sitting in the waiting room
every time there's like a ding that goes
on and it's like an office visit or
something and every time the dean goes
on the guy next to her stands up and
then sits down
and she looks at him like what is he
doing but then this dean goes on like
every couple minutes and he stands up
sits down
and then before you know it she starts
doing it and there's like two people
like i think there's two or three people
that are in the room doing the same
thing like they get in they start doing
and she doesn't even ask
why are you doing this she just starts
doing it and then all those three people
leave and then new customers come into
this waiting room who are also part of
the experiment
and she still does it even when no one
else is in the room because you've just
kind of oh this is what i need to do
while i'm sitting here without even
asking asking and then those other
people all start doing it too like
eventually one by one they all start
doing it i'm like
what is going on with the human psyche
it's actually amazing to me yeah well
we're hurt animals we are individuals as
i've said many times but we are also
hyper-social
animals and in most cases
going with the majority is
is
safe and kind of works
right because of the way we're hardwired
i mean if you imagine i don't know say
you were walking down a street and all
of a sudden you see
like
dozens or hundreds of people running
in the opposite direction to you yeah
looking scared
you should probably run with them just
in case just in case right like
something is ahead coming in your
direction that all these people are
running for right there's a small chance
it's a social experiment but probably
not exactly right so there there are
situations where it makes sense or
you're walking all of a sudden everybody
ducks yeah right right
there's a loud noise everybody maybe you
should talk to it it makes sense right
there's
so it makes sense so
we are programmed to take social cues
like you can see it in in babies and
children right people mirror
and that's how we are however
it doesn't mean that the majority as i
said there is is always is always right
or always makes sense well if it makes
sense that's the question you have to be
like does this make sense why what's the
why i always want to know the why
exactly and you're right about you bring
up children there's two things i want to
bring up one about the children i love
the tweet that you did which i usually
reposted on my instagram stories about
uh the more the older i get the more i
realize that the best form of activism
we can do is raise decent children and
it's so true especially when you talk
about children mirroring us as adults
because we we really are they really are
like mirrors for us and they teach us so
much how to be so that we can help teach
them but anyways the other thing you
brought up you said something about
rhodes and it made me think about
government and how maybe people who are
thinking well you have to trust the
government on some level and it's not to
say that that we think there should be
no government like well let's give them
as little power as they can
to do the things that we need for basic
functioning in society like roads and
um you know basic aspects like that i
think i think there's a lot of there's a
lot that can be discussed that maybe
people don't consider and even i growing
up in high school i wasn't really taught
about this or maybe i just wasn't
listening in class because i didn't care
at the time but now i care and just
learning the importance of like what
really is the role of the government and
is the power and that's the difference
between america than like pretty much
every other country and that
it's our what you were talking about
earlier negative rights yes yes explain
a little bit about that yeah sure so i
was saying that the usa is the first
country ever founded where on a concept
of negative rights so that you have
inalienable
god-given rights that you are born with
and the government's job is to not
infringe upon them the government
doesn't give you your rights you have
rights inherent to you as an american
and the government is supposed to
protect them whereas in most of the
world and most times throughout history
all times throughout history the notion
really was that the government gives you
your rights and if the government can
give you your rights then the government
can take your rights uh you are
more of a subject
than a sovereign individual whereas in
the us at least traditionally and you
know millions of americans still embrace
this the notion is that no these are
those are your rights that's inherent to
you
and
the government is supposed to you know
protect your life and liberty
um
to whatever extent possible and not
infringe upon that so it's a very
different mindset culture and mentality
that stems from that and
yeah that's that's one of the
fundamental differences between the usa
and even other countries in the
anglosphere like the the uk or australia
that a lot of people don't understand if
you if you want to understand something
that um
makes this really clear i think the most
obvious one to look at is something like
the second amendment and
understanding why so many europeans or
australians or new zealanders perhaps
even canadians don't understand a
concept like the second amendment is
because they fail to see that that's
considered a you know the right to bear
arms is it's not the government telling
you you're hey you're allowed to own
guns it's like yeah you're allowed to
own guns and the government isn't
supposed to infringe upon that obviously
strong two-way advocates would argue
that that's been massively infringed
upon already but
it's it's just a whole different way of
structuring up
the
people
government relationship yeah and i mean
the gun thing could be the whole entire
episode in and of itself right like i
actually used to be very anti-gun rights
i would just listen to
you know the perspective about like
school shootings and yeah like doesn't
really you see other countries like in
britain like the police don't even have
guns so that would prevent shootings and
and i understand why people feel the way
that they do but then when i started to
learn and realize about like our history
and the importance of having guns be
able to protect yourselves from a
potential government that is trying to
take over too much power i see like kind
of um
there's again a nuance in both sides
which i understand for sure
uh but there was something else that's
going to bring up i can't remember right
now but i'll re i'll read the um
some of your tweets from this this 20
thread viral tweet
so you said propaganda is just as
effective in the modern day as it was a
hundred years ago
access to limitless information has not
made the average person any wiser which
you did you did you spoke on that
already yeah and then when suffering or
when sufficiently frightened most people
will will not only accept
authoritarianism but demand it
talked about that one and then one of
the end i really liked your 21 the bonus
one most people are fairly compassionate
and have good intentions this is good as
a result most people deeply struggle to
understand that some people including
our leaders can have malicious or
perverse intentions this is bad yep
that's a big one i think that's uh
and that's what leads to the constant
disbelief and unwillingness to accept
the notion
that this may not all be about health
and safety and security that's why
people really struggle with that one
because as you said most people are
decent yeah and we tend to project
our
values and ways of thinking and
principles etc we tend to project that
onto other people and it's really hard
to understand like okay let's take an
example so
it's virtually impossible for any
[Music]
reasonable and decent person to even
fathom
how someone could be like a serial
killer or a school shooter yeah true
right like you can't even
because
you are you're
it doesn't
logically
make any sense because
you're projecting
your goodness
onto everybody else like you're not
accepting that
evil is a real thing and that there are
people who are
evil and or psychopathic
right so like
you you can't even
you can't understand it you you can't
really just get get in that person's
brain and be like oh okay you know i i
get where they were coming from or if
you do you yourself feel like you're
becoming a psychopath right like you
almost don't want to be able to fathom
it and
people in power as we already said are
not there are people who are
like that who have been in power in the
past and in the present
right so you can't
so so it's it creates this i don't know
maybe it's a type of cognitive
dissonance
where people
absolutely do not want to believe
that someone could have that
such malicious intentions that oh my
gosh like they actually want people to
die or they actually want people to
suffer whatever because you don't want
that i don't want that yeah nobody i
know wants that so but i recognize
that exists yeah recognizing that it's
not a big it doesn't have to be a big
chunk of people no it's just a very
small group of people yeah and this is
not me saying that you know everyone i
know tons of i know plenty of
politicians i know people in in
government i know all kinds of people in
the healthcare industry and science i
know i know lots of people
um so this isn't me saying oh all these
people are corrupt or they're all bad or
anything very very very far from it most
people are doing their best and most
people are trying to do good but that
doesn't mean that though everybody
higher up in the chain
shares those sentiments or doesn't have
that agenda and also just due to human
psychology
you know people are
people are afraid so there are people in
there's tons of people in the world of
science and healthcare and all these
different things who are afraid to speak
up about a lot of things that have been
happening in the past 18 months they're
afraid to they're they've been
threatened to have their medical
licenses revoked yeah they're afraid of
losing this they're afraid of losing
that they're afraid for their families
they're afraid for their job they're
free so
when that happens
people will
stay silent when they actually should
be speaking up
ethically or when they should be voicing
certain concerns or they should be
whistleblowing on certain things that
are going on i think that once that
starts to happen by the way i think um
man i think some heads are gonna roll
from all of this
like i think that there's
i don't know how long it's gonna be but
i think down the line when
more
things come to light
which might not be for a while it might
get worse it might not yes it might get
worse before it gets better but i think
that when certain dominoes start to fall
there's going to be some people who need
to be if there's any justice in the
world there's going to be some people
who really need to be held accountable
for a lot of the damage and chaos that
they have caused especially in
situations where it's been intentional
and there's been a lot of intentional
yeah and that's actually one of the
beauties of america i remember what i
was going to say now when you were
talking about america and negative
rights is that america also has their
individual states so if you don't like
what your elected officials are doing
and mandating or not mandating you can
go to a different state which is really
really cool and something that growing
up i didn't pay attention to or think
about it at all and now it's like wow
they really thought this through when
they were when they were working this
out the founding fathers of america um
you know for for the flaws of men of
their time their ideas that they put
down on paper were fantastic it's
amazing how now that's really the
narrative that we're not seeing
especially amongst young people is that
like that's not the case that you know
which is really interesting to me it
could be like an entire
a whole other discussion but i do want
to segue a little bit into a slightly
different topic because the way that i
found you
was through a candace owens episode
and then after that i was recommended by
my friend mariana who we are mutual
friends with um a video that a different
interview did called the problem of
black lives matter and one of these
quotes that i wanted to read that you
had said in a different interview i've
watched all your interviews i think
thank you
for a lot of them
um is that you said i think one of the
worst things you can do especially if
you're a young person is to convince
them that they're some kind of victim
and that the world is against them and
that they're oppressed especially if
that's not actually true because
whatever lens you view the world through
is going to be your reality and that
last sentence rings true for what we've
just been talking about but the
beginning part is like a different topic
per se
but um you want to get into that a
little bit because i think i think it's
fascinating yeah sure this is me simply
me saying that
instilling a victimhood mindset into
anybody let alone a child
during their formating formative years
is
i was about to say evil
but i don't think that's always the
intention but it's bad and severely
limiting
to them and their future
i think as human beings it's important
to it's why i talk about personal
responsibility victim mentality mindset
and all of that a lot because your
mindset does determine your reality and
your outcome
it really does and there's lots of
different ways you can view the world
and throughout this conversation we've
even
flip-flopped and changed between various
views right you can view the world with
a very pessimistic lens you can view it
with a very optimistic lens you can view
it through the lens that
human beings are evil and horrible and
cruel to each other and life is full of
suffering and we're all going to die and
we're all going to get sick and there's
disease and there's pestilence and
there's violence and all of that's true
right but it's also true
that
we're living in the most prosperous time
ever in one of the most some of the most
prosperous countries ever and we have so
many opportunities and there's love and
there's friendships and there's
relationships and there's children and
there's so many ways we can help each
other and uplift each other all of that
is also true
right and
depending on how you adopt the mind
frame
that totally changes
it changes your results over time
so if you go into the world assuming
that
the world is set up against you
right that everyone people are out to
get you maybe that's based on your race
or your gender or your sexuality or your
religion and you know people are out to
get you and the system the structures
are all set up to oppose you and to stop
you from succeeding and
all ex-people are why and all why people
are b and this and that if you walk
around every single day wrapped up in
that mentality
it's going to play out for you
right you'll be hypersensitive to
absolutely everything and you'll think
that people are being
aggressive towards you when they're not
even
you're gonna be offended by everything
you're gonna limit your own
uh you're not even gonna work as hard as
you could because
you know if you believe that the game is
rigged
then you don't wanna play you don't want
to play so it's actually important to
believe that
the game is
not rigged otherwise you drop out before
before before you even play so that's
why i oppose this sort of victim
mentality so much because it it
encourages people to have what i call an
external locus of control which is that
things are just happening to you you
know their systems and their structures
and there's things in place that are
just
acting on you
and in this case holding you down or
oppressing you whereas if you invert
that and you have an internal locus of
control you act upon the world so the
things i want to happen in my life i
make them happen
right i don't i'm not just sitting there
blowing around in the wind in the world
life is just happening to me it's like
no i'm going to do that i'm going to do
that i'm going to create this i'm going
to build that i'm going to connect with
that person and you are then really
powerful and very sovereign you're not
just allowing yourself to get blown with
the wind and let people bully you around
it's like no like
this is how it goes and then you you
take the responsibility it's like you
know what if something goes wrong that's
on me right i make a mistake that's on
me i'm owning that also i have a success
that's on me i'm responsible for that
there's risk right
absolutely um and so that's really a
sort of expansion of of that point there
what about like equity versus equality
how are we defining them
i guess the term
these days about equity is like that
everyone ends up with the same outcome
okay terrible idea yeah so terrible idea
um
antithetical to freedom because humans
have different capacities and make
different choices if you have a free
society equity is absolutely impossible
and undesirable because you can't have
it given the diversity of humanity and
you can't have it's antithetical to free
choice
um
also it's
unachievable unless you grind everyone
down to the bottom right as has happened
when they've tried communism in the past
right yeah the only way we're all equal
is if we're all dead that's the only way
um because human beings have different
capacity some people work harder than
others some people are better than
others at certain things
across every level no two human beings
in this world are the same so the notion
that they should have the same outcome
is nonsensical so equality of
opportunity as much as it's possible um
all for that it's also a little bit of a
myth that true equality of opportunity
is even
possible yeah um
because again we all have different
starting points and so many things that
that we do not control
but i think you don't choose what cards
you're dealt
but you choose how you play them
especially when you're an adult right
through childhood there's going to be
some things that are just
out of your control what about when
people say like well we got to make it
try to help the starting point be more
more similar for people so that it's not
such a drastic difference well do you
want it to be similar or do you just
want it to be decent enough for
everybody yes those are two different
things true
right because you never want to be
pulling people down you i'm all for
lifting people up i'm very against
pulling people down if it's like oh
those people have too much we need to
pull them down i think that's in that's
a perverse mentality yeah if it's like
oh those people don't have enough let's
lift them up i'm all for that yeah and
you can lift up one group without
denigrating another group and this is
something that a lot of
movements and activists need to realize
right so
if you are trying to uplift women you
don't need to do it you don't need to
tear down men
to do that absolutely if you're trying
to uplift black people you don't need to
tear down white people or asian people
or any other group if you are trying to
uplift um
someone who people who are homosexual
you don't need to
tear down
you know the straight people cisgender
right
yeah so i think a lot of people in this
world have this
zero-sum mentality where it's like oh
every time somebody wins or is getting
something they're inherently taking away
from another person if that guy has a
billion dollars
or 10 million dollars he somehow took it
from
somebody
else like that's all nonsense like that
person having a billion doesn't stop you
from having a billion
right yeah like that's not how it works
it's not zero sum there are a few things
in the world that are zero-sum you know
if you're playing a football game like
only one team can win you can't both win
yeah but generally across all the
different games we have in life you can
excel and win in different things and
what's great about life is you don't
need to win in everything right you
could just win one you get to be really
good at one thing
and be incredibly successful like you
might suck at like
almost everything but you're just really
good at that one thing and actually the
world is set up in a way in a free
country
where that's enough yeah and that's and
people love that that's awesome because
you can get in where you fit in oh that
guy's amazing at basketball cool oh this
guy's so good at math oh this person is
a fantastic doctor this person oh this
guy can build things this person's
really strong or fast or whatever cool
you can get in where you fit in and you
can try a lot of different things and
you can see what you're good at and then
you can build your career and your life
around the thing that you're good at
which hopefully you're also interested
in um and find fun to some degree and
that's how
everybody wins right it doesn't mean you
all end up with the same
salary or you end up with the same
wealth or you end up you know looking
the same or whatever yeah but
all all that's available and i think
that's i think that's beautiful i think
that's actual
diversity i think that's actual
uh inclusion and all of all these words
that people like to use
i think people need to actually think
about what they mean
and
not just
parrot lines and say words that make
them sound good or feel good in their
social standing but to actually really
think of what it means same with the
word tolerance
right people like to talk about
tolerance but sometimes the people who
talk most about tolerance are the least
tolerant people out there
and i'm like no like you have to
practice actual tolerance that doesn't
just mean
coming back to what we were saying at
the beginning being friends with or
associating with or following even you
know people who just agree with you as
much as possible but understanding look
there is a diversity of thought out
there there are different
ways of thinking different perspectives
people have different belief systems and
you don't need to accept or support all
of them you don't need to advocate be an
advocate for everything but tolerant
just means okay
i can coexist with that
that's really what it means
that was really well said and i think a
lot of people who might be in line with
the equity thinking are it kind of goes
hand in hand with what they think about
like capitalism and they might think
like capitalism is like the root of all
evil because there may be more thinking
about like crony capitalism and maybe a
lot of people don't know the difference
i actually didn't know the difference
until a couple years ago like really
understanding that there's like a
corrupt
um segment and section within capitalism
versus like true free market capitalism
and i came across this video just trying
to explain what socialism or what people
think as equity would do in like a
classroom where they said like hey look
all the people in the class we're going
to start doing socialism with your
grades so whatever the average is out of
all your grades we're just going to make
that for everybody everybody's going to
get that same grade so a lot of people
are on board at first like cool let's
try it out and then and then they get
back their grades and it's like oh the a
students who studied for you know
multiple hours multiple days they end up
getting a b minus average because that
was the average so then next time
there's a test they're like i'm not
going to study as hard if i'm just going
to get a b minus and then before you
know it the average grade is down to a c
down to a d and it just keeps going
lower and lower because the people are
like well i studied so hard and i didn't
get that
that what i deserved from that studying
and that that was really eye opening for
me yeah it's a race to the bottom yeah
um
competition is
competition is good in most things when
i say competition it doesn't mean people
have to be
physically fighting or at each other's
throats all the time but
competition leads to
better results and people should be
rewarded for hard work and competence
right somebody who works hard and is
competent and is good at what they do
and offers something of value
should be
compensated more than someone who just
wants to sit on their butt and play
video games all day for example yeah
right there's nothing controversial
there that's just
that's just how it is you put in the
work and
you will be rewarded to some extent some
things are
some skills and abilities are
valued more by society and by the
economy than other things
and that's just how it is right you know
someone might think that
it's ridiculous that oh man a football
player shouldn't earn you know a
thousand times more than a nurse does
right somebody may believe that maybe
not a thousand times i know 100 times
whatever it might be um
but
the a better question is
why do you why does society value
football so much
yeah right a better question than why is
that football player being paid 10
million dollars and that firefighter is
being paid i don't know 60 thousand
that a better question is
why are we so
into football
why so many millions so into football
that it's a multi-billion dollar like
that's a more interesting
question because if you understand that
then it's like well the guy's being you
you can't pay somebody more than they're
worth
for any long period that's the beauty of
free market capitalism yeah you can't
pay in demand exactly yeah so
and then it's also funny because people
who tend to pocket watch like this as
well i call it pocket watching uh like
carrying how much other people are
earning yeah they themselves often will
then be be like oh you know money isn't
everything money doesn't matter whatever
i'm like okay then stop pocket watching
like why do you care how much another
man has
if
you don't think money is all that
important like if you think money is the
most important i don't i don't think
money is the most important thing in the
world far from it yeah right i think
it's important i don't think it's most
important thing in the world and i base
my action on that i know people i
personally know people who earn
literally
more than 100 times more than me
like personally i know them and
i don't care yeah it's a source of
inspiration yeah it's inspirational as
opposed to like a you know because the
comparison thing is a thief of joy
instead of just like looking i'd be like
wow i want to look at someone instead of
being jealous be like what do they have
what did they do to get to where they
are today you know and if it's someone
you admire and you really like what
they're doing yeah i mean we we talked
about so many good things uh i'm sure we
could go on and on and on and we have
the week to hang out we've been talking
a lot i'm so glad we had this
conversation thank you for everything
that you shared i think we should just
end it here nice one i really i really
appreciate it thank you and i hope the
listeners have uh can take something
positive from this as well yeah
definitely check out zooby and you know
definitely listen to his own podcast
i'll be talking about that in the intro
so cool
[Music]
you